- You've probably heard about
some of these bizarre legal defenses.
The Twinkie Defense, what
could that possibly mean?
Or if you've been on Reddit
you might have engaged
in a thought experiment
about what would happen
if one of two identical
twins committed a murder.
They look exactly the same as their twin
and they share the same DNA.
Well, the thing is these legal defenses
have actually been made, and
some were actually successful.
Well, sort of successful.
It depends on who you ask it. Partially...
Look, the law is complicated,
I don't know what to tell you, but...
(cheerful music)
So stop me if you've heard this one.
DMX, the rapper, plays
one of his songs in court
and receives a reduced sentence.
Well, this actually happened.
In April of 2021, the
world lost Earl Simmons,
better known as the stage name DMX.
A successful rapper,
songwriter, and actor,
DMX undoubtedly had
tremendous impact on music
and pop culture.
But as often the case for entertainers,
with fame and fortune follows addiction
and a litany of legal troubles.
And since 1986, DMX has
been jailed 30 times
for a variety of offenses,
including robbery, assault,
carjacking, drug possession,
pretending to be a federal
agent, and tax evasion.
But the reason we are
talking about DMX today
is for the unique defense
offered by X's attorneys
at his sentencing
hearing for his tax case.
And in what sounds like a contrived plot
to an '80s movie no one actually saw,
the day was saved in part
thanks to the power of hip hop.
♪ It's true I got the bars like candy ♪
♪ But spitting verse like me ♪
♪ Will get you all up in the Grammy ♪
(record screeching)
- No, no, not like that.
Definitely not like that.
But in July of 2017, federal
prosecutors charged DMX
with 14 counts of tax fraud.
The government alleged
the DMX owed 1.7 million
in unpaid taxes from income
earned between 2002 and 2005
and had failed to file
taxes from 2010 to 2015,
where DMX had made at least 2.3 million.
Pro tip, not legal advice:
always file your taxes,
especially for a five-year period
where you're making millions of dollars.
But in November of 2017, DMX
changed his plea to guilty,
and prior to sentencing,
prosecutors were seeking
the maximum penalty for
five years in prison.
So enter the father-daughter legal team
of Murray "Don't Worry Murray"
Richman and Stacey Richman
who decided to try a
novel music-based strategy
to convince U.S. district
judge Jed Rakoff to be lenient.
At DMX's sentencing hearing,
Murray Richman argued
that his client suffered
a nightmarish childhood,
which had led to repeated
encounters with the law
at an early age and set him
on a bad path as an adult.
To illustrate his point, Murray
requested that Judge Rakoff
watch his client's music video
for DMX's hit song "Slippin'"
that lyrically describes
his traumatic upbringing.
Growing up, DMX was
abandoned by his father,
lived in extreme poverty,
endured severe psychological
and physical abuse from his
mother and her boyfriends
who knocked out DMX's teeth
and left prominent scars
on his face as a young boy,
and then was introduced
to drugs at 14 years old.
Murray argued that watching
this video would show
how DMX was not a bad person,
just that his difficult upbringing meant
he was simply not prepared
for the responsibility
of having lots of money.
The judge agreed to watch the video.
And after listening to the
song, Judge Rakoff remarked
that in the eyes of the
court, DMX was a good man,
noting, "In many ways,
he's his own worst enemy."
Judge Rakoff then gave
DMX a reduced sentence
for one year in prison
and ordered him to pay
2.3 million in back taxes.
After sentencing DMX, his
co-counsel, Stacey Richman,
explained the rationale
for playing "Slippin'"
for the court.
- This was about the
humanity of one person
reaching out to everyone else,
and it's not about getting a path, a pass.
It's about getting a path.
- And after learning about this case,
I'm gonna have to talk to my clients
about their bizarre lack of hit songs
to support their cases.
I mean, I can't do all the work for you.
But that brings us to the Twinkie Defense,
which is a very derisive term
for a thing that actually happened,
though it is incredibly misunderstood.
The most common legal strategy
for defending murder suspects
is to deny all allegations and
force the government to prove
every factual element of their case.
But when there is no dispute
that the defendant committed the crime,
defense counsel will often shift
to the defendant's mental state
to show why the defendant
is not legally responsible
for the crime and at a minimum
deserves a less severe charge
than first degree murder.
And such as the case with Dan White,
a former San Francisco city
supervisor who assassinated
then-Mayor George Moscone
and Supervisor Harvey Milk
in a rampage at city hall,
turned himself into the police,
and then confessed to the crime.
- Well, I'm definitely a law and order.
I campaign very hard on
what I consider to be
the number one priority
not only for my district,
but for San Francisco, and that
is to make this a safe city.
- Now this has been the
subject of several movies,
but here's the pertinent
actual background.
On January 8th, 1978, Harvey Milk became
the first openly gay elected official
in the history of California.
A fervent advocate for gay rights,
Milk's first official act on
the board was to introduce
a bill, which passed almost unanimously,
outlawing discrimination
based on sexual orientation
in employment, housing,
and public accommodations.
Milk's famously brash
brand of liberal politics
frequently brought him into conflict
with that of conservative
fellow supervisor Dan White,
a 32-year-old former police
officer and firefighter.
For example, White was
the lone dissenting vote
against Milk's
non-discrimination ordinance.
Tensions between the two
began to reach a boiling point
when Milk cast the deciding vote
in favor of opening a halfway
home in White's district
for troubled adolescents.
White stated that he
felt betrayed by Milk,
who had initially promised
to oppose a halfway home,
and soon became disillusioned
with the Board of Supervisors.
11 months into his tenure,
White abruptly resigned
from the board on November 10th, 1978.
White claimed that he could
not support his family
on a $9,600 salary
and announced that he was
leaving politics for good.
Four days later, in response to pressure
from conservative-leaning
police and business groups
who feared that the mayor
would appoint a replacement
who would create a six-five
liberal-conservative split,
White sought to withdraw his resignation.
Although Mayor Moscone initially agreed
to give White his job back,
the mayor changed course
following an outpouring of outrage
from White's constituents who blasted him
as ineffective and inattentive.
On November 27th, 1978, the
mayor was set to appoint
community activist Don
Horanzy as supervisor.
Angered that his plan to return
to the board was thwarted,
White then showed up at city hall,
slipped into a window to
avoid metal detectors,
and confronted the mayor at his office.
When the mayor refused White's
demand to be reappointed,
White proceeded to shoot and
kill the mayor execution style.
He then walked down the hall
and murdered Harvey Milk
as well, murdering his former colleague.
Both Moscone and Milk immediately
died from their injuries.
Soon, then-acting-Mayor Dianne Feinstein
made the stunning
announcement to the press.
- Both Mayor Moscone and
Supervisor Harvey Milk
have been shot and killed.
- Oh, Jesus Christ!
- Oh!
- The suspect is Supervisor Dan White.
- Later that day, White visited
his former police precinct
to turn himself in and
confess to the killings
in a recorded interview.
- [Dan] And then he
started kind of smirking
'cause he knew, he knew I
wasn't gonna be reappointed.
And he just kinda smirked at
me as if to say, "Too bad."
And then I just got all
flushed and hot and I shot him.
- The assassinations roiled
the city of San Francisco,
resulting in an outpouring
of spontaneous support
and mourning from the community.
And at trial, the
defense counsel for White
argued that White's longstanding
and untreated depression
gave him what's called
diminished capacity,
such that he could not distinguish
between right and wrong,
and thus lack the required
intent to be found guilty
of premeditated first degree murder.
Remember that the difference
between first, second,
and third degree murder usually depends
on the mental state of the accused.
Dr. Martin Blinder, one of
the five expert witnesses
called by the defense,
testified in the days
leading up to the killings
White, known for being
focused on personal health
and fitness, cast aside his
normal habits, grew stubble,
and in lieu of his normal healthy diet,
indulged in junk food.
Blinder testified that
White's excessive consumption
of junk food, including Twinkies,
which were only mentioned in passing,
where evidence of his depressed state
that had exacerbated his
already existing depression.
And the jury bought this
diminished capacity defense
and White was convicted
of voluntary manslaughter
rather than first degree murder.
He served five years in prison
of a seven-year sentence.
Less than two years later,
White returned to San Francisco
and committed suicide.
Outrage after the verdict led
to a series of violent events
in San Francisco that would be known
as the White Night Riots.
And following intense negative publicity,
in 1982, California abolished
the term diminished capacity
as a legal defense
and replaced it with something
called diminished actuality.
Under this new standard,
evidence of mental illness
is admissible to show a defendant
lacked the specific intent
to commit the specific crime
in which they were charged,
as opposed to the prior standard
that could be used to show
that the defendant lacks all capacity
to have any specific
intent to commit any crime.
And as you can imagine,
many people were upset
about the outcome of the White trial,
which is where the Twinkie
Defense name comes in.
In stories covering the trial,
San Francisco satirist Paul Krassner
played up the angle of the Twinkie
and claims that he may
have even coined the term
the Twinkie Defense.
Derisive reporters covering the trial
seized on the testimony made in passing
that White had eaten Twinkies
in the days leading up to the murders,
adopted the Twinkie Defense framing,
which led to decades of misunderstanding.
And due to this misreporting in the press,
much of the public erroneously believed
that White's lawyers
had argued that Twinkies
drove White to commit the murder.
In reality, White's lawyers
argued that the junk food
was a symptom of his diminished
capacity, not the cause.
But this misconception that
White received a lesser charge
by claiming junk food
made him commit murder,
which was repeated at the end
of the 2008 biopic "Milk,"
persists to this day.
Nevertheless, the actual defense advanced
was still controversial
for successfully reducing
White's charges from
murder to manslaughter.
Since then, some commentators have argued
that the so-called Twinkie
Defense was less pivotal
to White's defense then was the
relatively conservative jury
who possibly supported and sympathized
with the former supervisor.
It was reported at the time
that when the jury listened
to Dan White's recorded murder confession,
several of them actually wept.
And today the term the Twinkie Defense
has become a derisive catchall label
for improbable legal defenses,
like the ones that we're
talking about in this video.
And during the oral argument
in the Supreme Court case
of U.S. versus Gonzalez-Lopez,
the late Justice Antonin
Scalia famously referenced
the Twinkie Defense do
suggest that the right
to select one's own counsel
is perhaps more important
than the right to have
effective assistance of counsel.
The justice argued that, "I
don't want a competent lawyer.
"I want a lawyer to get me off.
"I want a lawyer to invent
the Twinkie Defense.
"I want to win."
And now we know why lawyers
get accused of being unethical.
But now let's talk about
one crazy legal hypothetical
that you'd think you'd
only cover in law school,
but actually happened in real life.
What happens when an
identical twin commits murder?
If, like me, you were
raised on TV in the 1990s,
then you know that the sure-fire formula
to ensure wacky hijinks
is to introduce twins
into any situation,
have them switch places,
and then let the shenanigans unfold.
Remember those classic
episodes where Tia and Tamara
switch places so they could take tests?
Or Mary Kate and Ashley switch places
to get their parents together?
And who can forget that
time that Zack and Cody
were arrested for drug
trafficking in Malaysia
but narrowly escaped the death penalty
when authorities couldn't tell them apart?
Oh, wait a minute. That's my bad.
That actually wasn't a special episode
of "The Sweet Life of Zack and Cody."
That was a real case where
twin-based shenanigans
actually prevented brothers
from being executed.
In 2003, Malaysian authorities arrested
27-year-old identical twins
Sathis Raj and Sabarish Raj
for trafficking large amounts
of opium and cannabis,
which in Malaysia carries
a mandatory penalty
of death by hanging.
The police had caught one twin red handed
taking a car load of
drugs to another house,
which only he had the key.
And then shortly thereafter,
the other twin arrived
and was promptly arrested.
At trial, the judge acknowledged
that the first brother
who was arrested with
a key was the only one
with access to the drug house,
and therefore was the only one the state
could be able to prove was
guilty of drug trafficking
beyond a reasonable doubt.
The problem?
Due to the twins' identical features,
it was impossible for
the arresting officers
to determine which twin
had been initially arrested
with a key to the drug house.
So further complicating the case,
the twins refused to admit to any crimes,
refused to testify against each other,
and the DNA evidence was inconclusive.
Unable to identify the
twin originally arrested
in possession of the drugs,
the judge acquitted both men.
In explaining her decision
to acquit the brothers,
High Court Judge Zaharah Ibrahim noted,
"This is a very unique case
as they are identical twins.
"Even the DNA evidence
could not prove anything
"as the DNA could be either
Sathis' or Sabarish's.
"I can't be calling the wrong
twin to enter his defense.
"I can't be sending the
wrong person to the gallows."
Or to explain this case using
only "Simpsons" references--
- He can't kill anybody if he doesn't know
which one's the real Krusty. (grunting)
- Now I would like to tell you
that this case is an outlier
and that there isn't some identical twin
exception to criming.
Unfortunately, convicting individuals
with identical twin siblings
remains an ongoing dilemma
for law enforcement.
More often than you would think,
suspects have been acquitted
or have charges dropped
when authorities can't
prove which twin is guilty.
One problem in these cases
is that eye witnesses
who struggle to identify the twin
that committed the actual crime.
For example, in 2011,
19-year-old Orlando Nembhard
was charged with shooting
and killing a man
outside of an Arizona nightclub.
However, when evidence revealed
that his twin brother
Brandon was at the scene,
prosecutors dropped the charges
when the witnesses were unable to identify
which brother pulled the trigger.
So as you can imagine,
reasonable doubt can be built
right into these cases.
This isn't a legal issue per
se. It's an evidentiary issue.
You have to prove your case
beyond a reasonable doubt.
And if you can't identify
which twin it was,
then you have a pretty uphill climb.
Now this video isn't over yet.
There is an extended version
of this video over at Nebula
thanks to today's
sponsor, Curiosity Stream,
who is running a 42%-off
sale for the holidays.
Here is one criminal defense
that I definitely couldn't put on YouTube,
how Lorena Bobbitt got off.
(image whooshing)
I mean, why Lorena Bobbitt
was found not guilty.
And I am thrilled to announce
my first Nebula original
"Bad Law Words Good."
It is a long-form
documentary where I explore
all of the most common legal
and linguistic comments
that people throw around in
everyday life incorrectly.
It's a hilarious romp through
legal misunderstandings,
logical fallacies, and
"Law & Order" parodies.
And it's only on Nebula,
which you can get for free
with today's sponsor, Curiosity Stream.
Because Nebula is a place
where we can experiment
with content and release things
that we couldn't put on YouTube.
And we're thrilled to be
partnering with Curiosity Stream
because they are the go-to
source for the best documentaries
and long-form educational
content on the internet.
They even have an entire section devoted
to unsolved mysteries and crime.
So if you like my videos,
you'll love the stuff on Curiosity Stream.
And we worked out a deal
where if you sign up
for Curiosity Stream with
the link in the description,
you'll also get a Nebula
subscription for free.
And to be clear, that Nebula
subscription is not a trial.
It's free for as long as you're
a Curiosity Stream member.
And right now Curiosity
Stream is offering 42% off
their annual plans.
That's the best sale they've ever run,
and it's less than $12 for the entire year
for both Curiosity Stream and Nebula.
So if you click on the
link in the description
or the link that's on screen right now,
you'll get both Curiosity
Stream and Nebula for 42% off.
Or you can go to
CuriosityStream.com/LegalEagle.
It's a great way to support this channel
and educational content directly,
and it's the only way
to see my documentary
"Bad Law Words Good."
So just click on the link
that's on screen right now.
Plus clicking on that link
really helps out this channel.
And while you're at it,
click on this playlist
with all of my other legal
entertainment videos.
So click on this video
or I'll see you in court.